the White House is reportedly
considering supplying cluster Munitions
to Ukraine that's despite human rights
groups urging both the ukrainians and
Russians not to use the controversial
weapons which are banned in many
countries reporters have been asking the
NATO Secretary General what he thinks of
the possible move
it is for individual allies to make
decisions on the delivery of weapons and
Military supplies to Ukraine
and so this will be for governments to
decide not for NATO as an alliance
uh
we are faced with a brutal war and um
and we have to remember that
this brutality is also reflecting the
fact that we every day see casualties
and that
close diminutions is used by both
sides or class missions are used by both
sides and Russia used custom Nations
in their brutal War aggression to invade
another country while Ukraine is using
it to defend itself
uh the best way to end this brutal war
is for President Putin and Russia to
stop attacking another country that's
also the
best way to stop all the suffering the
casualties
and uh and the death we see caused by
different types of weapons on the
battlefield every day
before we go further into this what are
cluster Munitions well the missile
canisters contain hundreds of smaller
bombs bomblets if you will the break
apart in the air with a widespread
devastating impact the international
Committee of the Red Cross says that as
many as 40 percent of these bomblets do
not detonate they fail to detonate and
that's what poses a risk to civilians
often decades later cluster Munitions
are banned by most countries they're not
banned however by the United States by
Ukraine by Russia as well as some other
countries Human Rights Watch accuses
both Ukraine and Russia of killing
killing civilians with cluster Munitions
all right our White House correspondent
Kimberly halket joins us now Kimberly
what's the thinking at the White House
on this
yeah well the thinking is that there has
been a bit of a Slowdown in terms of
Ukraine's counter-offensive against
Russia and as a result of that lag
what the feeling is is that the supply
of Western Munitions is going to become
increasingly scarce and so there was a
need for some sort of new Boost if you
will to this offensive and so as a
result for months there has been an
ongoing debate between the Pentagon the
White House Capitol Hill in terms of
what more could be done and although it
has been long controversial the use of
the cluster Munitions this is something
that has been discussed and just this
week it became clear that the decision
had been made as recently as in the last
24 hours that announcement was imminent
so we're watching very carefully to see
this come down we are expecting it from
the White House as you point out this is
controversial given the fact that 120
countries have banned the use but as you
also point out the United States is not
one of them
yeah cluster bomb is a dangerous for
civilians ultimately that's why they're
so controversial so why does the U.S
feel the need to send this particular
type of munition as opposed to another
one have they addressed that in any
significant way
well we're going to watch carefully we
have a briefing that is upcoming with
the National Security adviser Jake
Sullivan in the coming hours it's also
important to note that you'll remember
when the commander-in-chief also the
president of the United States Joe Biden
came into office what he said was the
foundation of his foreign policy was
going to be human rights yet what we've
seen time and again is sort of a blind
eye being turned at different points in
his presidency when it comes to Human
Rights and this would be another one of
those intersections where there has been
this deliberate choice to kind of look
away and use something that is
controversial and could deliberately
harm humans and and civilians we know
that the use of cluster musician
Munitions has a very high dud rate if
you will some statistics point out that
it could be as high as six percent we
also know that the scarring of the
landscape can be an impact for decades
that means that this failure rate these
golf ball sized Munitions can explode
for for often 10 20 years or more
harming civilians so the in terms of the
reason why they are being used again it
comes down to the fact that the White
House is really not sure where else to
turn and is looking for something to
give Ukraine that boost these are the
questions that are going to be posed to
the National Security advisor again
we're looking for that brief and coming
somewhere sometime after about 17 GMT
now Kimberly that's really interesting
you'll keep a surprise Kimberly halck at
Al jazeera's White House correspondent
thank you
now Sarah Yeager is the Washington
Director of Human Rights Watch and Sarah
you're joining us from Washington DC
today your reaction to the U.S possibly
supplying cluster Munitions to Ukraine
eating and it's devastating for several
reasons one is that it has been a norm
in the world that cluster Munitions
should not be used the fact that Russia
is using them is just another reason why
they should not be used they are
absolutely awful for civilians
um and of course you know I think when
legislators and policy makers here in
the United States see the photos coming
back of children with missing limbs
parents injured killed by our own
American clustered Munitions there's
going to be a real Awakening to the
humanitarian disaster that this is uh I
feel I know what you're going to say to
this but so the U.S has made the
argument that its cluster bombs have
less unexploded ordinance uh right again
we have to go back to how this works
right this is dangerous because a lot of
the little gulf-sized
um uh Munitions do not explode they end
up exploding later on unsuspecting
civilians including children right the
U.S says well our rate of Duds is lower
than some others and therefore less
dangerous for civilians your reaction
well they're still dangerous to
civilians they are still indiscriminate
and in fact I would love to see the data
from the Pentagon on where they tested
these clustered Munitions because
actually if you test it on asphalt
versus a field versus a an ongoing war
zone the dead rate is going to be very
different and we actually don't know
which variant they are using there are
lots of different variants of cluster
Munitions that the U.S has in its
stockpiles so we have been asking for
the data members of Congress have been
asking for the data and the Pentagon has
not supplied it yeah also perhaps not
not completely surprising you mentioned
International Norms but actually it's
about 120 countries give or take a few
but about 120 countries in the world
that have signed the convention on
cluster bombs so that still leaves a
chunk of 70 plus countries that haven't
including the US so they are not bound
by any International Convention not to
use these
they are not they are bound however by
Congressional legislation that says and
for very good reason that the United
States will not transfer cluster
Munitions with over a one percent dud
rate that is why President Biden needed
to sign the waiver and the reason that
Congress did that was because these
weapons are so dangerous and in fact
what I think we're going to see is that
Ukraine has been fighting this conflict
for the most part with a high moral
ground and they have been abiding by
international law for the most part now
they are going to use cluster Munitions
and I think because cluster Munitions
really have not been used
um in the recent past by Nations that
believe in international law and
humanitarianism even in times of
conflict that we are going to see
conflicts change after these are
transferred right how do you continue to
say you're on the right side of this
conflict if you use this particular type
of munition you make you make very
interesting points Sarah Yeager
Washington director at Human Rights
Watch thank you very much thank you